à elle maintenant
voici qu'à les oliviers
est ce que je peux dire une petite chose
je voudrais remercier djamel saluer
parce qu'il a parlé du maroc il a oublié
de parler de l'algérie comme j'ai de la
famille là-bas je laisse famille mais
les ouvrages
voilà une soirée spéciale reçoit bonsoir
les amis on soit retiré des amis de la
famille allez monaco avant de commencer
une question que tout le monde se pose
mais c'est vrai que la réponse pourrait
que à tuer l'intérêt de votre film qui a
tué pamela rose
alors le coupable c'est à huy chaque
fois qu'un mec le ceva c'est un film qui
s'appelle donc mais qui a tué pamela
rose 5 millions d'euro s et la gomme ou
qu'un vrai c'est la gaumont qu'est ce
qu'on dit à la gaumont merci sympa la
gomme au quand même
et en plus ils font 400 salles pour la
sortie donc une arme 400 ça c'est pas
venu échapperez pas quoi qu'on peut la
malle jour non c'est même pas la peine
d'essayer d'échapper à ce film vous n'y
échapperez pas alors ça film qui est
réalisé par eric lartigau
il est parent avec lartigau avec
lartigau cagnotte ouais départ avec
personne mais non il peut pas être
parent avec quelqu'un c'est pas possible
ça tout de suite homme il est tout petit
il est ou frites et alors avec vous il
ya donc gérard darmon jean-paul rouve
thierry frémont françois cusey alain
chabat à la chabal sera toujours bien là
je dois aller
alain chabat il a fait partie d'une
troupe les nus de la compagnie créole
compagnie créole est bon pour le moral
c'est bon pour le moral
julien va faire indices de reprise la
compagnie créée à l'origine a fait
chanter les nuages déclaré qatar oman et
qatar
ouais ça pourrait marcher désignant les
productions du même logiciel
et ça va et ce jusqu'au des achats
chabat nous a demandé de faire deviner
avant le film vous pouvez pas ça le
plaisir point de vue parce qu'on adore
alain évidemment mais beaucoup de gens
sur le m et il fait un chanteur de
country
elle suivra et nature alors le pitch je
fais ou le fait thierry renommage en
hommage au passé nous en étions là quand
ils sont passés voir de séparation est
ce que tu peux faire le pis s'il te
plait je suis le pitch est alors rippert
et bulitt sont deux agents qui
travaillent pour le fbi ils sont envoyés
à burnsville où une jeune stripteaseuse
dénommé pamela rose est retrouvé
assassiné dans une chambre de motel a
requis à c'est toute l'histoire est là
il fait heurte aux policiers locaux
emmenés par le shériff marleix qui joué
par jean paul rouve et l'animateur de
radio joué par gérard darmon fille
s'appelle phil cannon voilà un parfait
c'est génial c'est le début or à celle
là prénom comment vont-ils faire
voilà après comment vont-ils faire pour
trouver l'assassin effectivement alors
ce qui est extraordinaire dans le film
c'est que c'est un film qui a été tourné
dans la dans la banlieue parisienne
oui et qu'on se croirait aux états unis
on se croit vraiment à burnsville c'est
tout à fait étonnant
vous avez dit et c'est vrai le premier
film américain entièrement français
washington est à créteil
oui un siège du fbi a hissé la cité
universitaire du xiiie arrondissement
exactement c'est incroyable c'est
peut-être ce pognon quand même
non bruit qu'elle fait par un chien ça
va ce prix les utiliser à castillonnès
de la plus tournée là-bas largement
l'argent mis plein les fouilles
c'était génial c'est marrant et
franchement drôle d'aller tourner à
mennecy à créteil 1 ils ont ma ville
dont la clé tout le tour de parler ainsi
tenwick elle est comme ça le soir vous
rentriez à la maison affrontera la
maison tout cas bien failli à une vraie
intrigue d'une réelle très soignée
qu'est ce que je peux dire de plus -
c'est un peu drôle aussi nos thierry
meyssan va le voir en regardant la bande
annonce est à manille